thank you all so much for joining uh the
info session today I'm excited to get to
chat a little bit about the ignite
program with
you so my name is Kelsey I'm the
associate director responsible for
ignite programs here at the Stanford GSB
I've been running ignites for a little
over seven years now um and I'm really
excited to be uh launching this program
again in
2024 um the other staff that run the
program are colleague Xing the two of us
are kind of the logistical and
administrative staff and then Yosi
Feinberg who's the faculty director for
the program so he is the one responsible
for the curriculum teaches a number of
the sessions and does check-ins with
participants
throughout and ignite is a rigorous
academic program and our goal is to
teach you the fundamentals of business
as well as the more practical aspects of
launching a startup so that you have a
toolkit that you can use to drive
innovative ideas forward our goal with
Ignite is not only to teach you how to
launch a business but also to give you
those skills that you can apply even if
you wind up not launching a startup or
you know trying to run a small business
but instead go into a bigger company and
want to work on more Innovative projects
within that
company in order to achieve this goal we
have a dozen of the most senior and
experienced professors at Stanford GSB
who come in and teach um tailored
content based on their MBA and MSX
classes so typically these faculty spend
most of the Year teaching quarter long
classes to MBA students and then for
ignite they you know pair it down to a
three-hour session that really focuses
on what they feel that entrepreneurs
need to know most about whatever topic
it is that they
teach there are sort of three main
components to the ignite program one is
the core business skills such as
marketing Finance or business models you
know the things that you would expect to
see a business textbook on and for each
of those as I mentioned before the
faculty who teach them have you know
really paired down to just a short
session that will give you the key
information that you need about whatever
the topic is um obviously you know even
if you spent the entire night program
studying nothing but marketing you would
still not know everything there is to
know about marketing by the end of
program but our goal is to make sure
that you know enough to get started and
to do the basics um it's hard to you you
don't know what you don't know and so by
having you know three to six hours of
instruction on um Finance or what have
you you then have a better sense of you
know you know enough to get started and
you have a better sense of what you
specifically will need to follow up on
learn more about based on what your
specific interests are in addition to
these core skills we also make sure to
incorporate a large number of Applied
skills these are things like
communication or negotiation um the
skills that while they aren't um while
they aren't you know necessarily as
academic topics they're really critical
if you want to be a founder or frankly
for whatever you're doing in the
business world it's never a bad idea to
study leadership or
Communication in addition to
these core or more General topics we'll
also have a few in-depth sessions on
entrepreneurship such as an
entrepreneurship session and design
thinking class even though there are
only a couple of sessions that you know
have a title that's really tailored
around
entrepreneurship um each of the topics
that you study each of the faculty
sessions will be primarily focused on
entrepreneurship Founders new Ventures
that sort of thing within whatever their
area of expertise
is in addition to the academic content
there's also a significant team Venture
project component so our goal is that
Beyond just gaining the academic content
you also are learning how to apply that
in a more real world setting to achieve
that we'll have everybody in Venture
project teams in which you're working on
a a project that's like a mock startup
throughout the program so for example
you know you'll have your marketing
classes and then you'll go out and do
user interviews and refine your you know
your Venture description and then come
back into do design thinking and learn
how to use that user interview data
you've collected to apply you know how
to how to make sense of all the
information you've collected and how to
use that to move your Venture forward so
we'll have a number of assignments and
faculty check-ins that help move the
Venture project forward and work kind of
in tandem with the curriculum of the
program um at the end of the program you
they'll also pitch to a panel of
investors so this is an opportunity to
pitch a full business model presentation
um to a panel typically mostly of
venture capitalists um you know Angel
Investors that sort of thing as well as
some experienced entrepreneurs who have
been in the in that position we don't
have any opportunities for funding for
startups within ignite however instead
of getting a yes or a no and you know
hopefully some funding uh we
have our pitches set up so that you're
then getting robust feedback from the
panelists this is not something you
would normally get if you were doing a
traditional VC pitch so because this is
an academic program you know we have the
VCS talk you through sort of what their
thought process is what they like about
your presentation what they didn't
whether they you know would have
considered funding you if it were um a
more you know a non- ignite pitch and
what you should do to improve that pitch
to ensure that if and when you do
deliver it to um a pan to a VC you know
you're ready to get funding and can put
your best foot
forward to support you in the Venture
projects we'll have a number of
assignments as well as several check-ins
with the faculty director so this is an
opportunity for your small team of
typically six participants to sit down
for half an hour or so with Yosi get
feedback on your Venture asking
questions and just have that smaller
group more um more intimate more
targeted um session with a faculty
member we'll also bring in a number of
collaborators from outside the GSB to
support you on your Venture projects so
we have guest speakers typically they're
successful entrepreneurs often who
participated in ignite a number of years
ago we'll bring in panelists and each
team will have a mentor that you're
paired with who can provide industry
specific feedback on your Venture
project and you support connections that
sort of thing as you work through the
program so there are a few benefits that
we hope that you'll derive from the
ignite program the most basic is just to
learn the language of business no matter
what you do Post ignite it's always
beneficial to just have that language
know the vocab um and whatever Direction
you choose to go in you want to make
sure that you're able to you know walk
into the room sit down at the table and
be able to actively participate in the
conversation know what you're talking
about um and know what people are
talking about around you we also want
you to develop skills to turn an idea
into a successful Venture the projects
you work on within ignite are suggested
by Phil participants and you know some
of them may very well go on to be
successful startups in the real world
after the program but some of them won't
be it's you know we consider it
successful if a team launches a startup
after the program ends and we also
consider it successful if someone has a
startup idea they're considering and
after doing night they realize this is
not it there is no way that I would be
successful with this idea as a real
startup um because you know it's a lot
better to work through that in the
academic setting you know in the safety
of ignite than to spend a year of your
life and all of your savings launching
that startup so whatever your project is
we want to make sure that you have sort
of this toolkit so that you can leave
ignite and then do a mini ignite on your
own ideas and future projects that you
may work
on uh we also hope to help you improve
teamwork and Leadership skills and
public speaking
skills throughout the program and um
also to expand your Professional Network
to include the ignite alumni as well as
mentors panelists guest speakers Etc who
come in speak and our ignite Alumni
network is now around 3,000 folks in the
Silicon Valley as well as around the
world we are I'm really excited that we
typically are able to have a really
diverse participant cohort in ignite so
we tend to have a number of participants
from you know large leading companies a
lot of the big names around the Silicon
Valley as well as a number of
entrepreneurs at various stages in their
um startup
journey in addition to that sort of
working professional component um we
typically about
5050 or a 50-50 breakdown in the cohort
of working professionals folks who are
actively you know working either at a
company or as entrepreneurs and then you
know the other half are Stanford
Graduate students and postdocs um from
non-b business
Fields so we expect to have a cohort
that has some local folks from the
Silicon Valley as well as some
International folks from um a variety of
countries and um grad students and
postdocs at all levels from typically
all of the Stanford schools except for
The Graduate School of
Business the program uh the 2024 program
will run from January 14th to March 7th
2004 and this will take place on
evenings and weekends for the most part
classes will be Tuesday and Thursday
evenings and then all day on Saturdays
there may be a couple of times where
something has to happen on like a
Wednesday evening um but we will do very
best to keep a very consistent schedule
so you're here two evenings per week and
then um on Saturdays on the weekend so
our goal is to make sure that if you are
working full-time or you know have
you're taking classes full-time you're
working in the lab whatever it is that
you're able to continue doing that and
then fit ight in around your existing
schedule before the official inperson
program launch on January 14th we
actually have an online component that
will start on December 5th so this is
when you'll have access to all of the
program materials so you can get started
on reviewing and preparing as well as uh
submitting idea Venture project ideas
that you would like to work on during
the ignite
program the standard tuition for
Stanford in night parttime is
$144,950 uh this includes all of the
course materials all the instruction as
well as a handful of meals social events
um it does not include room and board
unfortunately we aren't able to offer on
campus housing since this program
happens during the Academic Year so all
of the housing is taken up already by
students um but our team is happy to
support you on um you know Finding
additional housing in the area if that's
something that you do need um we're very
fortunate to have a um a generous
subsidy from the vice provos for
graduate education that allows us to
offer the program to Stanford
participants so that's current grad
students and post dos um for
$1,525 so in order to qualify for that
you need to either be a graduate student
or a postto during the program dates or
graduate at um during fall quarter so
your eligibility extends for one quarter
after you
graduate there are no grades or academic
credit hours or like transferable units
um that you would receive for
participating in ignite this is
considered a professional development
program so you'll receive a certificate
of
participation um and you know something
that you can add to your LinkedIn
include on your resume if you so choose
um but we aren't able to assign letter
grades for participation and ignite um
all of the assignments are reviewed by
The Faculty director but he will provide
verbal feedback in your check-ins rather
than you know letter grades or more that
more traditional grading
system we um always try to cap the
program at 72 participants in order to
ensure that you have you know a diverse
cohort you're getting to meet people
from different backgrounds and you know
build that strong network but that the
program is still intimate enough that
you actually are getting to know
everyone um you know through the course
of the eight weeks that you're on campus
our goal is to make sure that you have
meaningful interaction and are able to
be actively interacting with the faculty
and your fellow
participants the it is a selective
program we every year have typically um
a long weight list of folks who are
qualified who I would love to have in
the program but we simply don't have the
space so you know we do our best to get
everyone in um but we do also balance
that with capping the program size to
make sure that it's a really quality
experience for those of you who do get
admitted the application deadline this
year will be October 26th so you have a
couple of weeks left to complete your
application um the application includes
um an online application form and within
that is an opportunity to upload your
resume or CV um you'll need to request
one letter of recommendation through the
online application form and then you'll
also complete an online video
interview the online application will
include some short essays as well as
some brief information about yourself
typically for those essays um you know
it's important for it to be more than
just a couple of sentences we want to
make sure we get a clear picture of who
you are and why you're excited about
ignite but typically um two to three
paragraphs is about the right length for
each of the
essays for the recommendation uh you
should choose someone who can speak to
your Innovation skills and your
entrepreneurial Ambitions where possible
if you're a graduate student or a postto
you know a professor or um you know
someone in your lab is typically a great
choice you're also welcome to request a
recommendation from somebody else who
knows you in a professional capacity
such as you your manager at an
internship or a part-time job if you're
a working professional we typically
expect to see a recommendation from your
current manager however again if you
don't feel that that's the person who
can best speak to you as an innovator as
a team member
um you're welcome to request a
recommendation from someone else who
knows you in a professional or academic
capacity for the online video interview
um it's me it's we use a system called
Kira that is meant to sort of mimic the
process of having an in-person interview
but by being online the admissions
committee is able to watch it with your
application you know review it as many
times as they would like um and it winds
up being a much more useful admissions
tool than doing an in-person interview
would be so in order to get that sort of
in-person
um
interview experience online um you'll
see you'll get to see a question asked
and then you'll have 30 seconds or so to
collect your thoughts and then have two
minutes to record the response when you
go into the interview platform you have
an opportunity to do practice questions
I think we ask you to tell us about your
favorite movie something like that just
to you know get comfortable with the
platform make sure that you're prepared
for the interview and you can do those
practice questions as many times as you
would like um you can also leave the
interview platform and come back as many
times as you would like but once you
start the official interview you only
get one shot to answer the questions so
do you know plan accordingly and make
sure that you've done the practice
questions and gotten really comfortable
with using Hera before you go in to
record your official interview
responses
so that's actually it for my
presentation um I'm going to go ahead
and stop sharing screen my screen and
then welcome the panelists to uh turn
your cameras back on and we'll get
started with the panel
portion so today I'm joined by uh three
panelists who participated in the ignite
part-time 2023 program um
I'm going to go ahead and guess
panelists I'll ask you to introduce
yourselves so share just your name um
maybe a brief bit about your background
and then what you're currently working
on uh so we're going to go in order of
my screen so H Pepe will start with you
first hi guys uh my name is Pepe I
participated in ignite during the winter
part-time course uh I am right now
actually in Palo again I'm working on a
project that uh did not come out
technically out of ignite but from a
very good friend I met during the course
he was in my group and we sort of just
Blended well together so now we're in
this new Venture together it's quite
exciting uh Toni we go to you next hi
everyone my name is thi um I was a
Stanford student at the time of ignite
also did it almost a year ago uh I was
in the policy program and wanted to kind
of broaden my business Acumen so to
speak uh I have since graduated from
Stanford and I'm employee number three
at an agtech startup um so using quite a
bit of my uh ignite uh coursework as
well as you know things that I've
learned uh in my day-to-day so nice to
meet you all and hopefully I can answer
some questions that you
have great and then um have you will'll
go to you
next yeah hi um chabi um I'm also from
Pepes promotion um early this year um
I'm a former investment banker so I
spent um most of my professional career
doing Investment Banking in Spain um and
right now I'm working to raise funds to
set up a venture capital uh firm in in
Spain
so uh now uh panelist we'd love to hear
some advice from you on how you balanced
the demands of ignite and either your
career or degree program um chabby will
go back to
you yeah sure so um first of all I would
recommend you um all of you like to take
Serious ignite so probably um the the
classes are just part-time but the the
demands are pretty high so I I would
recommend like reading the cases in
advance um preparing the classes um
obviously the vure idea so um even
though the the classes may not take too
much time um I think there's some work
that you need to do in the background so
just take that in mind um just
to um organize
yourselves
great um Pepe we'll hear from you
next I also second what shabi said I
think that classes have a lot of great
content that if you do not prepare in
advance at least read the case studies
you will not be able to participate
adequately uh when I say read the case
studies I would say it takes about uh
depending on the class about an hour to
two hours per preparation per class
usually
uh which is not a great deal of time but
just be aware to not let it slip by and
on the weekends you'll get a little bit
more intensive as you'll have a 9 to5
Saturdays and then the short amount of
time that you won't be working you'll
want to continue progressing with your
own Venture idea so that you're not just
preparing for the case studies but also
going along with your Venture IDE and
preparing it to be presented to the
final panel
right um and teny will head to you next
yeah I think um for
me I think having a a clear sense of
what you want from the program when
you're going into it is really important
because I think that kind of helps you
prioritize there's so many benefits and
values that you know you can you can get
from the program and I think it can get
quite overwhelming especially if you're
balancing a full-time job or like me I
was a student as well as a research
assistant um and so time management was
a huge deal for me uh and really
understanding what my North Star was and
what I wanted to achieve out of the
program helped me prioritize where I
wanted to allocate time where I wanted
to actually spend time um and and where
I didn't want to do that and so to
ensure that you're making the most
informed decision to be able to have the
experience that you want to have out of
ignite um I think that having that going
into to the program and having that
nordstar going in is really really
important right so um love to hear next
um what advice you have for participants
that you wish that you would had when
you
started um and T VI will start with you
this time yeah I think that that's a
it's a good segue from my earlier
comment uh I think the time management
piece is definitely something that I
wish somebody had told me about about
because uh you know on the outset I was
very confident that I could do the 6 to9
uh during the week and then the Saturday
work um but I didn't quite realize how
intense my other schedule would be um to
where you know I had wanted to spend a
lot more time networking uh with a lot
of the faculty a lot of the students but
because by the time you know 8:30 rolled
around I was just forgive my French but
just pooped by the end of the day um and
so I really just making sure that you're
going into it with you know your eyes
open really understanding the demands of
the program uh as my colleagues had
mentioned uh what it takes to actually
do well in the program outside of the
program as well as in the designated
times is really really important um and
fully you know understanding what other
uh priorities you have and what other uh
time commits commitments you have uh
during the
program thanks um shaby love to hear
from you next
yeah sure so in addition to what Tami
said um I would also recommend you in
terms of logistics if you come uh from
abroad like it was my case um probably
um try to share like probably a house
between some of you like I think having
a place for the participants of the
ignite especially from from the one that
that that come from abroad it's it's
really helpful to to have some place to
to meet everyone there and hang out a
little bit so I I think in terms of
logistics um and I think that the
program did it really well setting up
like a slack channel before the program
started just for all of us to to get in
contact and trying to set up those those
Logistics was really
helpful and and also probably renting a
car um I I think that that was really
helpful for me as well because um
actually the gsv has a parking that
has a cost but it's uh really nice to to
have a parking spot at at
gsv all right then uh Pepe let's finish
up with you I I would second chavy on
trying to you know rent a house with
others because it's great to share more
time and uh the B the cost in paloalto
is incredibly high like $2,000 a single
bedroom apartment so uh renting a shared
space you can a split the cost of the
living room get more out of it and B you
could also share uh the drives uh to to
and from the GSB because public
transportation is not very big in
paloalto that's a tip they gave me and I
will give it to you you
too um and also personal tips uh don't
be afraid to submit your own idea I
didn't because I thought that uh
everyone would submit world changing
ideas and that was not the case maybe
one or two ideas ended up being great
but we're all trying to figure out it
out so don't be you know don't undermine
yourself whatever you have it just
submit the idea it'll be fine if it's
accepted great if it's not don't worry
you'll pick up something and
99% it won't be the next big thing but
it's just one step forward to meeting
new people networking and that's my
second recommendation like my second
recommendation you're not just there for
stanf for ignite you will be there at at
Stanford so try to make the most out of
that too try to network with people try
to you know broaden your horizons talk
to everyone try to you know deep in your
network because it's a very unique place
to be and many of you that are not
Stanford students will get a once in a
lifetime opportunity and the ones that
are Stanford students you'll get an
opportunity to meet people that are not
from Academia but from the industry
which might have relevant knowledge to
other Ventures you will do now or in the
future or you know it's always good to
network with other
people well thank you all um for for
sharing your experience in the program
um we'd now like to open it up for
questions from you all the uh
prospective applicants here so please
feel free to um raise your hand you can
click the raise hand icon in the
reactions tab at the bottom of your
screen to raise your hand and uh then
unmute yourself and ask a question or if
you prefer you're welcome to send a
question in the chat and uh jaying or I
will will read it out for the
panelists uh we have some question in
the chat maybe I'll start with one um
for current student with previous
internship experience what the
recommendation preferably from academic
advisor or former
employer you know it really um this is
not a helpful response but it really
depends on your specific situation um I
you know when I look at applications
I've seen both and both can be great it
really kind of depends who you feel like
you have the strongest relationship with
definitely it's far more important that
the person who does your recommendation
like really knows you and has had you
know personal interaction with you than
it is that they have a very specific
background see I see some hands um Anand
would you like to ask your question
sure uh thank you Kelsey and Nang for
that session the the overview and and
thank you Pepe aier and P for sharing
your experiences very interesting
appreciate that uh my question is uh
mostly related to uh the how this the
ignite program relates to the Stanford
lead
program uh I mean I I just took the lead
program and I just graduated uh
recently uh but apart from the lead
program I also um participated in the
Lisa you know subprogram will you know
which is the the startup accelerator
within lead so I just wanted to get some
you know feedback on whether you know it
still would be you know relevant or you
know there are any differences in in the
curriculum and also potential outcomes
uh of for the
program yeah so you know I think that if
you have just finished lead ignite might
not be the right Next Step for you
simply because it's a lot of the same
faculty and I know that in lead they're
teaching um a much longer more robust um
course or um you know more sessions with
each Professor then you would get in
ignite so you know I've never done lead
myself
but I will say there's probably going to
be a lot of
overlap um of course the team Venture
project is you know unique to ignite and
the entrepreneurship spin is unique to
ignite but um the session content is
likely to have a lot of
overlap you um Yan
M yeah thank you for um infos session so
I'm currently a PhD student in um
epidemiology and computer science I
guess I have two questions in general
the first one is um do we have to have
any startup ideas a prior to the program
um the second question is that for the
recommendation letter from my adviser
because he's really good at writing
recommendation letters you know in
academic setting I guess like how does
this recommendation letter differ from
like applying for grass
school um all right starting with the
recommendation letter it you know will
ask specific questions in the
recommender form so we'll it will be
very clear to recommender what they
should say and I think it's maybe not so
different from a recommendation for for
grad school uh but certainly you know we
see a very wide range of backgrounds of
recommenders and the admissions
committee is prepared to um you know
kind of
translate different different
backgrounds and perspectives in Reading
those um
and then for the startup ideas you don't
have to have a startup idea to come in
but you you know if you have one you
should certainly mention it in your
application um it's you know the
admissions committee is always looking
for your excitement around
entrepreneurship and you know whatever
if you have a project that you're
excited about and you're passionate
about um definitely share that in your
obligation cool thank
you
M
CC hi uh hello everyone uh I have a
question like um does the ignite program
related to NBA program like I'm not sure
if uh how similar they are because I'm
also uh very interested in the MBA
program in in future and currently I'm a
a grass student at Northeastern
University so yeah that's my question
um The Faculty are the same so all of
the unite faculty teach in the MBA
program but the MBA if you you know
they'll prepare you for different things
if you want to be the CFO of a Fortune
500 company you should not do ignite you
need an NBA um if you are preparing to
launch a startup soon um You probably
don't have time for an NBA and ignite is
probably the right fit for
you
um we don't typic every once in a while
we do have igniters who will go on to do
an MBA post ignite
typically you people will come in
thinking that they might want that and
by the end of the program feel that you
know they have enough to get started on
their goals without you know going back
to grad school for an
MBA I
see um and can I ask um because right
now I'm pursuing a degree at
Northeastern University so I'm gonna
if I get in I'm GNA take the class like
part as a part-time student so do I need
to have any like visa for that like op
uh I'm not sure like if if I need to
transfer my Visa from my current
Institute to Stanford um no so we
actually can't sponsor visas for ignite
participants so because it's a
professional program it doesn't make you
eligible for student visa if you already
have a student Visa that allows you to
study at
Northeastern um that you know as long as
you are in the country have some Visa or
able to travel to California you are
good ignite staff don't care what kind
of Visa you have um most people will
come on I believe a tourist visa I see I
see thank
you uh
vicam thanks Kelsey and and thank you to
all the panelists for their time um I'm
a physician at Stanford and for one of
the weeks um of the ignite part-time
program I'm du to give a talk overseas
uh for a conference um I just wanted to
know um is that the sort of thing that I
should be opting out of and is there a
mechanism to stay in touch with your
team as you're working through the
program or um what would be your best
advice in that situation um that that's
totally fine most people will miss at
least one or two sessions just life a
lot of Life happens in eight weeks if
you expect to miss a very large portion
of the program right if you were going
to have to miss three full weeks you
know that would then be different but a
week would be acceptable yeah okay great
thank
you um all right
Bernard hey hello everyone um thank you
for today's session was really helpful
to understand more about the program uh
my question is so I already have an
start up in Brazil
and I like to to hear from you maybe
shavei as well if do you believe that
the the program has all of the
essentials to expand
globally um yeah I I think actually um a
couple of our colleagues they they had
also businesses in in their um base
countries and and they went to to the
ignite with with the same aim as you and
I think they they enjoyed the the
program I think they give you this
overall view on how to expand your
business and if for example you apply to
the program with your idea and your idea
is one of of the ideas to be developed
during the program you will have also a
lot of feedback from the professors and
and Yosi himself um on on the project
and how is the best way for you to
internationalize your business
perfect thank you so much
for
auar hey um thanks so much I had a quick
question about how this program differs
from the full-time um one in the summer
um if you could just highlight like what
the key differences are in terms of like
content um or is it just kind of the
schedule yeah so the the content is the
same it it is really just the schedule
uh
it's almost entirely the same faculty um
and it is the same the same topics that
are taught in each program both have the
same Venture project assignments that
sort of thing but you know one spread
out one condensed into about three and a
half weeks and in terms of like the
acceptance rate and stuff like are they
kind of sim and the number of
applications are they similar yeah
they're comparably competitive got it
and then one last question was for
Stanford posts um or students um I think
I saw something where like if you gra
like if you graduate you're still
eligible for like the Stanford rate for
like the first quarter after is that
right yeah so for part-time if you
graduate in the fall you're still
eligible for the student rate for the
parttime program for the summer program
if you graduate you know at Spring
graduation you're still eligible for the
reduced rate for the summer program okay
so you have to be within one quarter
yeah okay
thanks
uh
vasu yeah hi everyone thanks for the
introductions it's really nice very
excited I had one question uh actually
two questions one is um what kind of
focus do you have for people who are
working inside a company and they want
to start their own you know
entrepreneurial projects they want to
create a new product opportunity for the
company do you have uh is is the cours
work and the
uh material suitable for such uh such um
efforts and the yeah that was one
question I had yeah uh panelist do you
have who were um you know professionals
during the program do you have thoughts
on
that I think the the program uh aims not
just for a coursework that's for
starting a new application it's also for
uh entry and
entrepreneurship so many things that you
learn the program will also help you
during your current job it's not just
appli it if you want to Pivot and start
something new um in that term the
program is super flexible I I guess and
in the worst case you will get to see so
many other different people with
different backgrounds that will inform
you of so many things that I think in
turn all that information will be useful
for your current job most most of the
current applicants have not pursued
long-term their idea they went back to
their jobs but they're all very thankful
for their
experience thank you that's great and a
quick question on the application
process the video interview what's the
like goal or purpose of that interview
what are you trying to
evaluate sure you know it you know it's
it's essentially just another aspect to
evaluate you to Bal balance out with the
essays and across the essays your
recommendation um and your interview
what the committee is really looking for
is that you have clear goals for why you
want to do ignite like why ignite and
why ignite right now what you expect to
gain from the program right we want to
make sure that your expectations and
your goals are aligned with what the
program can offer um and also looking
for excitement and your passion around
entrepreneurship Innovation whatever it
is that you're working on um you know
that you're excited about that and you
know have the the the drive to use the
ignite content to do something cool
whatever that might be for
you
n hi I have a question about uh the
application process uh do you have like
a rolling admission policy I'm asking
because like you said you cap the number
of participants to
72 we don't do rolling
admissions we yeah the committee will
review all the applications at once and
then admit the the top 702 at that time
okay okay got it thank
you
see hi oh I just have another question
about the um the decision releasing time
like when would the decision be released
for this round sure so we anticipate
releasing decisions in um in early
November typically the first week or so
of of November depending on how long it
takes the admissions committee to review
everything and then after that time you
would have approximately four weeks to
um this confirm that you will be
attending and to remit
payment I see thank
you
there any other questions that um I
answer or that you have for our our
panelists right well panelist I have a
question for you um is there anything
that you know that was kind of
unexpected or that surprised you you
about the your participation in the
ignite
program I can take a step at that to
start us off um I don't know if this
should have been expected uh but I I
don't know why I didn't expect it but I
think the people are really the strength
of the program uh I think I made a lot
of really long-term person as well as
professional connections and
relationships through the program uh
that I really wasn't anticipating um so
for instance I was specializing in my
regular work in a in a in a very Niche
policy topic uh in the tech world and um
it turned out that there was somebody
who was doing that exact same thing um
at a pretty large social media company
um and we ended up having a great
relationship um that built into a
friendship that started out from this
professional um experience uh and I
think every time that you know you're
you're evaluating a program or
evaluating your fit in the program I
think it's easy to overlook the
interpersonal aspect of it um and I
think ignite does that really really
well is bringing in a diverse set of
people um in the same room to where any
discussions that you have with whatever
subgroup you find yourself in is always
really enriching uh and you always take
away uh a lot from those discussions so
I think that was really uh a standout
for
me yeah I totally agree and I also would
add that um the idea that you go to
ignite with like for example your
Venture that you would like to launch or
whatever you want to do with your life
after ignite um sometimes I think it's
going to change through the program
because or either you just test the idea
with the with Yosi or with other clees
during the program and you realize that
the idea is not as good as you thought
at the beginning or then you just find a
new friend and want to start a new
Venture with him um which has nothing to
do with your previous experience or with
your uh previous idea so I think it's
really good to go with an open mind um
and and try to get as much as possible
from the
program I will second uh what both of
you said um I came to the program with
an idea of learning something new and
specific and the things changed and I
switched venters after the program with
a friend I made doing the program I'm
literally now at his house and yeah you
don't know what to expect during the
program things will change but that's
good uh the program will definitely open
many doors for you all and that's what
you're actually paying for in the
experience I think that sound seems like
a great place to wrap up um thank you um
to the three panelists so much for
joining and coming in to talk about your
experience um thanks to everyone else
who joined tonight I hope to see
applications from all of you and meet
most of you in January um if there are
any questions that weren't answered
today please feel free to shoot me an
email um you can email through either
the website or reply to if you got the
reminder email today that email address
will come to jaying and I and we're
happy to help out with um whatever you
need to know however we can support you
in your
application and with that I have a great
rest of your evening and hopefully I'll
see you in IGN night
soon